how much did it cost you to start film
threat oh wow um well it cost me nothing
because i wrote a bad check and it
bounced
oh okay this is when we would write
checks for things so i
yeah to start film thread i mean i guess
the real investment was i bought a book
about how to publish a magazine
because
based on my college education i kind of
felt like well i'm paying them all this
money
to buy really expensive versions of
books and then regurgitate the contents
of those books in the form of essays or
questionnaires
when i can just buy the books and read
those books
recreationally to because being filled
with knowledge was the thing that was
important to me not proving to a
professor that i had read the book
but i bought a book from folio magazine
which is the magazine
about the magazine business it's like
variety for magazines
and i bought a book from them about how
to publish a magazine and read that book
and realize there was no way i was
going to be able to do it
but i um
the first issue was six pages
and i had
put it together i had like the logo
which i had created
and sort of a fan zine
i like the title film thread it sounded
punk rock and i was a big fan of um i
was a big fan of like
old school fan scenes they were mostly
about music and skateboarding and while
i loved music could not skateboard i
loved movies i wanted to do a fanzine
about movies film threat just seemed to
fit with all of those
so i met a guy named andre seawood at my
school at wayne state university and he
had written some very thoughtful essays
very complex about politics and film
most of which i didn't understand but i
thought well look here's a platform i'll
do jokes
and come up with sort of comedic things
and movie parody posters and whatnot
i'll write some reviews myself and you
can put your essays in this and
uh we put out this magazine we put out
the first issue which was six pages
and i wrote a check it was i believe the
check was for like maybe 50
and it it bounced there were only 500
copies of the first issue of film threat
um that were published but
but sorry who did you sorry interrupt
but who did you write the check to
kinkos so yeah i wrote i wrote the check
to kinko's and it bounced and i
there were charges from the bank anyways
eventually i then um
you know
paid that off and then i did
you know come up with a way by selling
advertising to be able to pay for the
magazine it wasn't expensive at that
level
andre and i parted ways
later and i wanted to really
get the magazine up to
a much higher you know not like a
12-page thing
i wanted to do something more
substantial
so i went into a printer and i said
i learned about this thing called credit
and i went into a printer in in detroit
and i said could you print this movie on
cred print this magazine on credit and i
had
walked in with a business suit that i
bought
from like value village
was the name of the place which was sort
of a salvation army i bought it at value
village for five dollars i walked in
with this suit i looked really
professional even though i was very
boyish looking face
at the time and i just said
well you printed on credit and they said
yes and i did this
i did the same scam
to another printer and then another
printer another printer to the point
where then like the sheriff's department
was like look you you have to pay these
printers money i had them coming after
me at the time i'd amassed a huge record
collection
um and sold it all to be able to pay the
printers off
so i basically just sold like all the
stuff that i had just to be able to
keep the creditors off my back and then
that actually got the attention of
an investor who thought that
film threat like oh this is crazy story
of this kid who was like defrauding like
printers in detroit
to print a magazine and so he decided to
invest in it
and then so there are very stages of
film threat there's the zine stage
getting it printed at like you know
off of a copy machine then the more
formal magazine stage
and then the stage where you know i sold
the magazine in and eventually sold it
to larry flint
um
and there's a whole story there where i
licensed it to him for a dollar which i
never got
but he didn't pay me anything for the
magazine what i ended up getting was i
got free advertising in the magazine and
i got a a budget to work with actually
so i sort of ca i sort of split film
thread into two magazines one being film
threat magazine which was published by
lfp
larry flynn publications and the second
magazine was called film threat video
guide which we and we had a rule that
any movie that was made for under say a
hundred thousand dollars really low
budget or underground films we put those
in film threat video guide and then film
threat magazine did the bigger budget
indie movies right the ones were made
for about a million or so
this was in the 90s and so we had sort
of cleared delineations and then we
would do a section in film threat called
underground where we would cover the
magazines or highlights of the the
movies that were covered in
film threat video guide
so they were like these sister
publications
and that led to creating a distribution
label where we put out
people like todd phillips his first
documentary called hated about gigi
allen and the murder junkies so we put
out todd phillips first documentary film
on vhs in the 90s
and
that sort of kicked off our company we
put out about 30 different films on vhs
and film threat video guide basically
championed those movies and the reason
that company started is because
filmmakers would come to us
and they would say we'd love to
advertise
our movie that we're releasing on vhs
ourselves
in film threat video guide we'd say okay
well advertising costs this much a page
and they'd say we don't have the money
so we figured out a way like well how
about this we're not going to get the
rights to your movies we're just going
to give you free advertising we'll do
fulfillment for you and then we'll pay
you a larger percentage of what the
money we take in
right so we did vhs duplication and we
were basically giving we never owned the
movies per se
it was like a licensed deal and then we
would sell these filmmakers movies on
vhs
at the time and built up like york
bucharet's film necromantic we put out
his second film dirtotis king
and he was a german filmmaker that
helped him get distribution in other
countries so we championed smaller
films made by like richard kern is one
of the filmmakers among others todd
phillips uh put out
um his his documentary and then we put
out a series of
short films put out by the new york
underground film festival so we had
these very distinct delineations between
the two film threat was the more
mainstream snarky giving the middle
finger to hollywood bigger budget indie
movies and then film threat video guide
was the smaller
underground films
and movies that we actually were
distributing and helping the filmmakers
make money selling their movies how did
you meet larry flynn how i met larry
flint was after he noticed me
i was writing humor and comedy for
hustler magazine
they had this section in the front that
was uh just sort of it was like mad
magazine but a very very adult version
of it and i wrote jokes for it
and
he
loved what i did he thought you know
that i did like movie parodies
uh i did a parody a film parody um
the revenge of anne frank
which was anne frank as a zombie
risen from the dead to kill nazi
skinheads
um i grew up in detroit around and
skinheads existed that would uh you know
and i i thought that they were very
obnoxious i did not like them
so that inspired me to come up with that
concept and that was
one among many of the the jokes
that i put in that section anyways he
really liked the stuff that i was
writing in there and
i pitched to
um jim coles who was the cfo of the
company i said look
i said hustler magazine is like a punk
rock adult magazine right you have
playboy and then you got hustler punk
rock at the time they published a
magazine called rip which was a heavy
metal magazine and rip is like this
angry you know punk rock
metal magazine it's sort of you know the
opposite of rolling stone i said you
know what you need you need a punk rock
movie magazine
you've got you know adult content you've
got you know rip magazine music how
about film and and that concept was
taken to uh jim coles who ran the
company at the time and
he he he loved the concept
so
uh i met larry flint it was it was
i mean it was uh
strange to meet him i mean here here i
am a college dropout he gave me an
opportunity and for for that i will be
forever grateful and you know
his his fight for the first amendment is
admirable
um
and it's you know a lot of the freedoms
we enjoy the freedom of the press things
that we're able to say are specifically
because of larry i mean he he really
nearly gave up his life for that
if you know about his history
so he was shot yeah i mean he was shot
and crippled you know
um so
but
larry was fearless i mean that really
inspired me with film threat at the time
as well i mean my passion wasn't
necessarily adult content um but my
passion was film and just
that he gave me a voice to be able at a
budget to be able to put out this
magazine at the time
um was pretty incredible
so
uh i i'm really grateful will always be
forever grateful for him giving me a
boost and and getting film threat
magazine on newsstands all over the
country
didn't anyone talk you out of
starting film threat i know you you
started it with someone yes college okay
my family tried to talk me out of doing
film threat they say they said it's
never going to make any money
and i will say this they're not wrong
film threat has
almost never made money it's it's break
even is a huge success
having said that break even with
breaking even with what we're able to do
in the indie film community i think is a
worthwhile trade
additionally
i wouldn't have had a a career on
television
or had you know offers to do books or
other opportunities if
i didn't have film thread as kind of as
this thing that i do so what film threat
really brought to me was opportunity
have i made money on it
no am i still here yes have i outlived
other media outlets
plenty and i feel that's i mean and
there would be little pretenders and i'd
see like other people start things like
oh that's really interesting let's see
how you do with that it's not easy to be
consistent it's not easy to have done
something this is now more than half my
life i mean it's i've been doing i
started film thread in 1985.
so i don't know when you're watching
this
or when you're listening to this
but i started at 1985 okay and film
threat is still around
maybe not in
the year 2100 who knows uh but um
still going still going strong
and so
uh
i i feel that there's
um respect for what we're doing and it's
just amazing to me that the mission
has
you know remained consistent at a time
when brands reinvent themselves and i
think reinvent themselves in a way that
almost like it just gets away from like
well what are you
you started this way now you're this
it's not what people are
um we've we've remained consistent um
and i i'll say it's um
there's been no shortage of sacrifice
for that
so they toss you out just just ask my
butler and by that i mean i don't have a
butler
okay
so they talked you out of it before you
left michigan yeah before i left
michigan my family was trying to talk me
out of
um
talked me out of you know
continuing to do film threat there was
always like i every time i'd reach a
milestone i would revisit it it's been
five years eight 1985 to 1990 i even did
like a fake tombstone photo shoot with
filmed the film threat logo on a
tombstone 1985 to 1990. i thought five
years is a good round number i'll stop
10 years is a good round number i'll
stop 25 years is a good round number
i'll stop but here i am
you know it's
you know
more than 30 years later and um it's
this thing that
you know i'm kind of burdened with
always being connected to
but it has brought me a lot of
a lot a lot of opportunity and and um
i i i feel gratified from the standpoint
of i have
i hope i have inspired some
filmmakers who who look at what we're
doing and and um
see that it's possible to get attention
the thing that does concern me is how
lazy the media is
i think that our mainstream
entertainment industrial complex
are
lazy
from the standpoint of they're pretty
much run by the press release that goes
into their inbox
and that and and run by publicists that
are effectively ghostwriting a lot of
stories
and there's a laziness from the
standpoint of this movie is opening on 6
000 screens so that's the movie i'm
going to cover
but there's 10 other movies that are
coming out the same weekend why
why are you not covering those
and that has been my frustration
i would probably
quit doing film threat
if there was some other outlet that just
paid attention or at least if one of the
larger outlets paid attention to the
small filmmakers so we review anything i
mean if you
send your movie to film thread if you go
and you submit it we have a little
submission system if you send it to us
we'll review it
um there's no i mean i would recommend
that you be somewhat beyond either
you're playing at a film festival
or you're about to come out in
commercial release
right and the sooner you submit it the
better it helps us out we get five or
six hundred movies submitted to us on a
monthly basis we try to cover about half
so we do our best
um
but uh
it it it just
disappoints me that when i meet um other
colleagues who cover film like i do
that we can sit there and talk forever
about the latest marvel movie but they
have no clue what other movies are
coming out
you know and i can sit there and tell
you about psycho gourmand or clapboard
jungle
or like a host of other movies that have
come out all different types of genres
to your last death an indie animated
comedy horror anime
i mean it's just like
these bizarre
movies that are coming out of all types
and there there's a complete lack of
awareness about them and there's an
elitism about them as well and i feel
and i'm sure i said this before in one
of the other interviews you need to have
a balanced media diet it is important
it's important that you see a film made
by a new up-and-coming filmmaker that is
just trying and it's like to me these
movies are like birds with broken wings
they are not perfect they are not
perfect and that's okay because
what i feel part of my role part of our
role at film threat is to kind of take
that bird and just let it fly as high as
it possibly can and to look beyond the
yes there may not be may not be
technically perfect there may be some
rough around the edges
you know things but you can see if you
can see a creative vision beyond the
flaws
i live for that i love that i love that
that sense of discovery that this is a
new creative voice that this first movie
this first short whatever it is
not perfect but some that
there's something there and if that
filmmaker can just get a little bit of
encouragement
to want to keep going
that that means a lot
so you've been a part of film threat for
over 30 years
but it didn't always rest in your hands
so you had larry flint flint
publications that took over it and then
how did you get it back from that point
well there were a couple times a phil
film threat
for me film threat is like a villain in
a james cameron movie you know like you
think you've killed it and it rises
again
so
um
i mean
the the first time was you know in like
1990 i decided i'm just gonna put film
threat down i'm going to go do other
stuff and then i was somehow able to
finagle larry flint to buy the magazine
and then
i went off to go work at a video game
company called digital pictures in
northern california my i was you know
tasked with making small low budget um
independent features that would also be
developed into video games a guy hired
me named tom zito they developed movies
called night trap
and sewer shark
you can look those up they were made for
like the sega cd this was the very first
cd-rom what they called full motion
video games so i worked for that company
and developed some
movie projects that would have also been
video game projects so we take you know
we've got an 18-day schedule to make the
movie then we add on six extra days to
make the video game well that was
short-lived and when i left
film threat was not in my hands anymore
i was not editing the magazine it was
edited by a guy named paul zimmerman and
film threat was always teetering on the
edge of profitability
and
you know the bean counters over at larry
flint decided to pull the plug
there were some people that were
interested in buying it at the time the
publisher of spy magazine and psychology
today had a group of magazines and
looked to purchase it that deal fell
through
paul zimmerman tried to find some
investors to purchase it to do to
continue to do it and then when all of
those deals fell through i because i had
left um lfp on very good terms i talked
to my old boss jim coles the cfo
and he uh he said look he said i can
give it to you but you have to take over
the subscription liability which is
about thirty thousand dollars
so meaning i had to fulfill the
subscriptions because that was the debt
that they had owed the subscribers who
had pre-paid for issues of the magazine
that were unfulfilled
so
i relaunched filmfare as a print
magazine in 1996 and we only put out
like two or three issues
um about two issues there was a third
issue that was about to go to press
and
it was very it was really depressing it
was so funny that second issue we put
courtney love on the cover because the
people versus larry flint was about to
come out
and i um who did we interview for that
was it the director
um
what's so funny is now this is i'm
having a shatner moment where um
people will walk up to shatner remember
that episode of star trek well people
walk up to me and they say remember that
issue of film threat and i'm like i kind
of have a vague memory but i usually i
have to check i don't actually have a
full collection of the magazine by the
way there i'm missing some issues of the
magazine in any case um
that was the last issue that was
published there was a third issue that
was that with we had a david lynch cover
story that never went to press because
this was 1997
and there was a paper crisis so a bunch
of things happened simultaneously and my
uh
you know
some people have a conspiracy theory
that they think that this was a way to
suppress alternative media i don't 100
believe it but at the time
there was a paper crisis and in in the
late 90s and they jacked up the prices
of paper additionally ad agencies that
had booked like cigarette and good
paying ads
they decided not to pay these small
publishers i'm talking about magazines
like the nose from san francisco bay
area among other like alternative press
we're talking about everything across
the realm humor music
film
and a lot of magazines went under film
threat being among them there were there
was it was like this perfect storm of
paper
raising in prices
distributors that couldn't pay us and
went out of business one in particular
in texas called flatland distribution
additionally another um you know
advertising agencies deciding to just
like not pay their bills i mean it was
it was fairly typical for an agency to
book an ad and pay you between six
months 18 months later
you had to plan for that you had to plan
for the fact that an ad that you were
gonna get paid like maybe eight thousand
dollars five thousand dollars you would
not receive that money for six months
that was normal
so um you had to always act like you
don't have money so that's
you know
that would be really good advice to
actors
when you get that big payday actors
don't pretend you don't have that money
pretend it doesn't exist
you know
learn to live inexpensively live a good
life but inexpensively and sorry who was
behind this conspiracy though who who
was who were they this is this is people
within the publishing industry felt that
because part of the reason for the rise
in paper prices because because the u.s
government would not allow
a um a type of hemp to be grown one that
did not make a type of hemp that could
be grown that could be used for paper
for magazines that would not make you
high that these plants would not
get you it would not alter
your and so so that actually would would
mean that you would not have to def
there wouldn't be no deforestation it's
replenishable you grow this type of hemp
a strain of hemp that doesn't get you
high
basically to use for paper for magazines
and newspapers but the us government did
not allow that to happen and because of
that paper prices went up
and that effectively
um
muffled the voices of a lot of magazines
in that period film threat being among
them
um
and i i'm not saying i'm saying i had
heard sure people
say that because of that
it was the government trying to suppress
alternative media political political
voices um
anyone that had anyone that had a voice
that was not the mainstream narrative
those voices were suppressed
it ended up being a blessing in disguise
because film threat you know collapsing
as a print magazine
led to us creating an email newsletter
that went out to about a hundred
thousand people we had built it up using
it wasn't intended for this at the time
but we used yahoo groups
probably no one remembers yahoo groups
but we used it as a way to do a blast
you could send notifications well we
just used it to send out our movie
reviews so we we created a thing called
film threat weekly which we put out
every week and it was just reviews of
movies the top box office we would
include jokes we would have a
quote from a movie at the top we'd give
you the volume number the date this is
very unsophisticated this is before you
know then then we had a website right
which was
html i've been through every incarnation
of the internet right html i know all
the like the dot php and the this like
i'm not particularly technically
sophisticated but i like to push the
medium as far as you can
the current incarnation of film threat
is built on wordpress but we use a lot
of customized things that are written
for it to um feature the movies i like
um
i know that we don't get as much traffic
because we don't if you go to
traditional websites there's stuff all
over the front page we don't do that
what i like to do is i want you to look
at and we feature every movie that we
review we feature on our home page
and if you scroll through that home page
it's i want to create the feel of the
cover of a magazine so that every
filmmaker whether it's a small film or a
larger film they're featured in a way
that features their the the photography
from the movie we we look for a key
image we call it the hero image and we
want to make it look we want we want to
make the film look really good
even if the review might not be good
it's not always good um we want to make
the film we want to present it in its
best light and we want to give it almost
a magazine feel that this is like look
how important this small movie is right
and we give those just as much attention
as we would give a big budget hollywood
release
so so uh yeah i've been through it all
film thread has lived and now there was
a time
you asked about film threat changing
hands
in 2010 i wanted to pursue um
uh i wanted to pursue other things more
filmmaking aspects and whatnot and a guy
who had worked for me mark bell
um who uh i'm still friends with and and
mark's just my hero for a number of
reasons i mean my family we're all very
close um mark um
he
took it over i wanted to like take a
step back and in 2010 um
mark took film threat over
and um
we agreed on a payment price that he
would pay for it and he would just pay
me a little bit like every six months
he'd give me a report and and pay me for
this amount that we had we had
determined
um as it is
he wasn't able to pay that off and the
rights to film threat reverted back to
me in 2015. um
i kind of put it on ice for a little bit
and i did a kickstarter that was not
successful
and i and i'll say this what i learned
about kickstarter is this if you want to
create a successful kickstarter
do an unsuccessful one first
because that's your market research
it tells you the things people like and
dislike about your campaign
it it informs you of
the the how effective your messaging is
secondly you'll see really what the
market is willing to bear i think i set
too high a price even though it was
really the money i needed
um
it was it was too high
um i relaunched the campaign asked for
less money offered different rewards and
film threat was relaunched in january of
um
with
some
some or most of our legacy content
intact
and we've continued to build build it
you know ever since
we post about five times a day on the
site generally about three reviews a
couple news stories or features
um
you know and then trailers we run a lot
of trailers that other trailer sites
don't run are you i still don't know how
to do youtube
so i youtube is a mystery to me even
though film threat does have a youtube
channel we do interview filmmakers and
we do movie reviews and we do movie
trailers
i don't know what people want on on
youtube so
um i know what i like and i like reviews
and i like interviews with filmmakers
and i like to see trailers that i don't
see on other traditional trailer
channels so we like to host trailers for
indie filmmakers that you wouldn't find
these trailers and other channels in
fact i know for a fact that our content
gets ripped off from our channel all the
time
um it's fine it's i mean trailer is a
piece of marketing it's advertising it's
good you know
if someone's looking to like bootleg the
trailer and put it on a different
youtube channel good let that happen
it's more exposure for the for the
filmmaker
it's more exposure for that movie
um but yeah film thread has changed
hands i've kind of like no matter what
even when i'm when
the periods in which i was not involved
with film thread people would always
blame me for it
so it seemed to be this thing that would
haunt me
um whether it was doing something good
or something bad i'd get credit when it
was good and people would be upset with
me it was bad and
you know um but there have been other
shepherds who have brought film thread
along um and i don't know if if it's
some foolishness or
just um not wanting to give up but here
i am like
you know
since 1985 doing a job
you know that was like right out of high
school i kind of created for myself
and what does your family say now
well yeah i get i guess my family like
they finally kind of see like oh wow
like like i see film threat stuff pop up
like it'll be in their youtube feeds or
it'll like they'll see a news story or
like
and you know they'll always be like a
story back in michigan where i'm from
um there'll be a story that pops up of
like
famous people from michigan and i get
mentioned in that which is really weird
to me
um
you know but i i i guess it's uh
you know i i guess now they're they they
recognize that hey i think they probably
like the tv stuff more because that's
more accessible to them than reading an
indie movie website but um you know
there'll be those stories that pop up
every once in a while when they talk
about and and so
they like it you know um what can i say
you know
when you were about to make the trip out
here to l.a were you 19 20 21 i don't
know i was in my early 20s it was 1989
so i was like 23
24 around there and moved to los angeles
and um
just loaded up a truck and came out here
didn't know what i was doing
moved into hollywood i don't recommend
hollywood
i don't recommend hollywood let me give
you some some advice here on moving if
you're going to move here
one if you are pursuing independent film
you don't need to move here
you don't you really don't i
um i i
you don't need to live in hollywood
that's for sure
what i like to do and especially now we
have the in whenever whenever i'm
looking to move is i will look at police
reports in the neighborhood i'll go to a
place i like
i use an app called i've used an app
called padmapper which is a great way
because it's g it's geo-based i find a
neighborhood i like first
you know i see houses or places in that
neighborhood and then
i like to live in a walkable
neighborhood i'll just say that
hollywood um people who live here will
tell you to not live there it's it's uh
crime ridden and kind of disgusting um
but i moved there when i first moved
here got out of my six months leaf lease
as soon as that was up
um and tried out every different area i
kind of lived in los feliz for a bit i
lived off melrose avenue i lived on on
the west side closer to santa monica um
i really like that even though it was
like prohibitively expensive but it was
really clean air
um
one thing that was very interesting
after i just moved to los angeles and
went to my doctor and i said you know
i've had these sniffles i felt like a
cold that won't go away for six months
because you didn't have a cold you
developed allergies you moved from one
location to here and the environment
like you have allergies
so i developed that after moving from a
different place
but i do think it's important to
really really check out that
neighborhood
and be mindful of your situation put
yourself in a situation where you're
going to be able to be productive
um
[Music]
productive you know in terms of your
work output
uh one thing um i live in pasadena and
pasadena is uh where castle green is
castle green is this beautiful you can
look this up castle green is tim burton
lived there when he was in school
famously wrote you know some of his
early work was written in the little
atrium that is at castle green and if
you ever see castle green in pasadena
um you'll see why it inspired his early
work
um you know frankenweenie uh beetlejuice
you know uh peewee's big adventure you
could see that like oh this this this
inspiration this beautiful old building
and a lot of movies were shot at castle
green it's quite the location a lot of
weddings happened there but now it's all
condos
it's been it's this old hotel that have
been turned into condos and he lived
there i do think that your
my living space for example and where i
work and find inspiration is really
important to me
i have
things that inspire me whether it's like
you know
toys that i had from when i was a kid i
have a dune sand worm
that i got when the original david lynch
dune came out um certain books will be
facing forward so i can see the cover of
those books
i do think that a spate your creative
space wherever that is
is just really important and i've come
to enjoy
when i find these on youtube
the term the friend told me is it's like
either ambient or slow tv they call it
slow tv which is a thing where it's just
sort of
a sound and it just sort of gets you
into that trance like in the zone so
that you can work really effectively and
i i will uh i usually consume a couple
hours of slow tv a day to get into that
space so i can get certain tasks
accomplished
um
so i think really be mindful of that if
you're healing hearing helicopters in
your neighborhood um
probably not the best neighborhood to be
in and there are places on the outskirts
of la proper that i think are they're
beautiful parts of burbank glendale
pasadena north hollywood that i would
strongly recommend and if you could live
in a walkable neighborhood that's great
too and even better a walkable
neighborhood close to the metro
i live three blocks the metro i can hop
on the metro and boom i'm in downtown
l.a i can hop in the metro and boom i'm
at the tcl uh theater in in the heart of
hollywood right um and they're expanding
those lines um
you know some of some of these metro
lines are going to other parts of la
that
it's just exciting because it didn't
exist when i first moved to los angeles
you know that didn't exist in 1989 they
broke ground
it was like what 91 92 they broke ground
on building the metro now it's
everywhere and i i take it a lot i like
having to not have to worry about
parking
and
i don't know parking in la that's a
whole other that's a whole other episode
you